Hello everybody.
I'm standing in front of the Aikido Headquarters this morning
and we're getting ready to celebrate the new year.
The Kagamibiraki ceremony is also the occasion to learn about the new promotions to the subsequent Dan grade,
Ueshiba Moriteru Doshu will be awarding some of these promotions himself during the ceremony
and he will follow it up by a short demonstration.
Afterwards, we'll all be meeting
to celebrate the New Year and these promotions
while enjoying some sake and some mochi cake, the traditional rice cake.
Kagamibiraki literally means: "opening the mirror"
and this is either represented by the cracking pen of a cask of sake,
or by the braking of the traditional mochi cake.
Symbolically, it means that
people would look at themselves through this mochi cake,
and reflect on the year that has past.
The tradition comes originally from the Tokugawa era
where they used to crack open a cask of sake
before battle for luck,
which subsequently became a tradition.
So I'll give you a little tour of the Hombu Dojo
and I'll explain to you what's going to happen during this ceremony.